Figgis as you may know I purchased a new
laptop cooler for my new laptop and it
was basically to replace this one I have
a 17 inch laptop this is not for a 17
inch laptop hmm so I bought the NZXT
cryo LX
google it it's sweet so anyway as you
can see what a title this is my unboxing
video please enjoy this extremely large
box I know it's in here this is my first
hardware unboxing it's called the cryo
LX it's the NZXT cry OLX notebook or
Stan USB it's got Newegg written all
over the box
[Music]
hopefully it's it's it's an all-aluminum
notebook cord with three fans 320
millimeter fans it uh it has a 4 port
USB hub on the back and it's gonna power
this baby this 17 inch HP Pavilion eb7
T
a lot of peanuts basically super large
box for it
and that's the large package so the
world's largest it says it's the world's
largest full Wynnum notebook cooler
I think that was backwards for you guys
but you get the point
full aluminum I'm about to unbox it now
okay here we go it's got its
and it is freezing cold because first of
all they do give you a little before
they do that it's telling you it
features a USB cable for powering fans
gives you basically the whole you know
everything you need to know about it
nothing to ask all right here's what's
in the box
basically this USB to power cable right
here USB power and another USB to USB
2.0 but don't worry I'm not losing two
USB ports or yeah I am but I'm aiming
for there's a black version and a silver
version now I know how it works cuz this
is really really cold to the touch
and that's silica gel think this one's
massive also hey like I said she's cold
I've stopped this on the back there are
four USB 2.0 ports that means they will
power a they will power a external hard
drive they will power your flash drives
your mouse thing or whatever I really
have a USB hub over here
but Wow the other thing on the back is
this other this is the power these are
the four USB ports and this is where you
plug in for power and plug it in for the
USB hub and obviously on the right-hand
side there is that control fan control
up and down it's convenient and I'm not
sure how to show you these three fans
yeah yeah you can I think you can see
that those are three huge 120-millimeter
fans so for comparison since you
probably don't have someone sitting
around obviously it doesn't have a USB
hub but it keeps it off the ground to
little tiny fans and a USB to power
that's all it needs power there on the
side cost me ten bucks so you know it's
plastic so it does not even passively
cool this is just freezing this is gonna
be like my travel one put on my lap this
is not for your lap it'll freeze your
lap solid and then and then it will burn
away cause it's heavy so also I forgot
to mention there's these rubber feet I
forgot its wings closes portability but
not really here's a rubber tons of vents
three huge fans and I feel like this
will never warm up because it's
completely frozen solid right now the
rubber your laptop will not move on the
bottom on the other side there's your
rubber feet one here here
here you keep your laptop on the ground
you didn't go move and that's it I hope
to get a camera to review some you know
to actually go around it and show you a
picture of it with the laptop on top
here I'll show you this is the old
15-inch laptop cooler which was stupid
cuz on a 17 inch laptop on top of it
yeah no no no no chance here
it's just I'm gonna get speed fan
running and I'll post in the description
the difference in temperature that I get
from you know using stuff thanks for
watching
alright I hope you enjoyed that unboxing
video I will hopefully reveal it more
and get over all the other features
about it but until then thanks for
watching please subscribe